bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 8 février
l'aviation israélienne bombarde la nuit
dernière plusieurs sites industriels au
liban les dégâts sont très importants
israël récuse l'accord de protection sur
les populations civiles au liban sud
yahoo victime d'une attaque le deuxième
réseau de sites internet au monde a été
mis à terre par une augmentation
artificiers du trafic nous vous
expliquerons comment les négociations
sur les 35 heures dans la fonction
publique interrompu à 4h ce matin
reprennent ce soir les syndicats ont
demandé aux ministres de revoir sa copie
une histoire exemplaire de résurrection
social avec la reprise par des mineurs
du pays de galles de leur puits que l'on
disait condamné un documentaire en fait
le risque
un concert pour le groupe the cure et la
sortie d'un nouvel album le groupe
anglais des années 80 un peu vieilli que
tu maintenant la mélancolie et nous
commencerons avec une inquiétude au delà
des pyrénées comme un regain d'action
raciste en espagne le quotidien
conservateur abc titrait ce matin à
madrid on nationale tout cela après des
émeutes fomentées contre des immigrés
maghrébins en andalousie une soixantaine
de personnes ont été blessées et l'on a
conseillé à tous les étrangers immigrés
de ne pas se rendre à leur travail
des patrouilles raciste se seraient
formés pour mettre le feu dans des
quartiers habités par des immigrés dans
la ville de hay lhériteau 7 au sud de
l'andalousie où une usine a été incendié
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi
commentaire sophie mais elle
c'est une véritable chasse à l'homme les
violences ont duré trois jours trois
jours d'émeutes de folie de haine
déversée sans limite dans les rues de l
et fido petite ville d'andalousie plus
que là sans histoire
tout a commencé samedi matin une jeune
espagnole est assassiné par un
déséquilibré le meurtrier marocain lui
et les siens devront payer le prétexte
est tous choisis pour tous les
xénophobes que compte la région à et les
rideaux la situation gronde en sourdine
depuis longtemps les étrangers
représentent près d'un tiers de la
population
beaucoup de marocains notamment sont
venus travailler dans les exploitations
agricoles
alors ici ne sont plus tout à fait chez
soi les manifestations racistes de ce
week-end ont rapidement viré à
l'expédition punitive matraque au poing
ici la police tente d'éteindre
l'incendié d'une maison qui abrite sept
marocains
plus loin on ferme les commerces
précipitamment pour éviter qu'ils ne
soient dévastées travailler toutes ces
années et regardez qu'est ce qui lie à
quel est le problème la police était là
les gens cassé la voiture sous ses yeux
pourquoi
la nuit dernière une usine de recyclage
de plastique a été incendié le bilan de
ces trois jours de violences est lourd
une soixantaine de blessés
aucun nouvel acte de violence n'était
signalé depuis ce matin mais la
situation reste tendue
la communauté maghrébine a voulu
répliquer aux attaques racistes
nous ne sommes pas des assassins
pouvait-on lire sur leurs bannières une
bonne partie de la population libanaise
s'est réveillé ce matin sans électricité
sans chauffage c'était la conséquence
des raids violents multiples et massif
de l'aviation israélienne tout au long
de la nuit bombardant des installations
électriques près de beyrouth dans l'est
et le nord du liban
il y aurait 18 blessés parmi la
population civile il ya surtout la
crainte d'une escalade armée
commentaires florence mavic soudain
l'ennemi noirs des environs de beyrouth
crépitent s'embrase comme une
gigantesque torche
il est minuit 25 heure locale
l'aviation israélienne vient de toucher
sa première cible la station électrique
relais de jamioulx à 10 km à l'est de la
capitale libanaise
deux autres stations électriques l'une à
baalbeck dans l'est du pays l'autre aden
bout tout au nord sont également
bombardé une partie du liban se
retrouvent sous le choc
au petit matin c'est la consternation et
la colère de la station relais de
jamhour il ne reste qu'un squelettes
calcinés de la ferraille fondu en sept
mois
cette centrale électrique a déjà été
écrasée deux fois sous les bombes bilan
de ces raids israéliens 18 blessés parmi
la population
pourtant des blessés civils il ne
devrait pas y en avoir en 96 après une
campagne de raids massif et meurtrier
baptisé les raisins de la colère mené
contre son ennemi juré le hesbollah il
fait elle avait signé un accord de
cessez le feu
les deux parties sont engagées à ne pas
commettre d'action mettant en danger la
vie des civils
aujourd'hui israël estime qu'il n'est
plus tenu de respecter cet engagement
cet accord de protection des civils a
été régulièrement violée depuis quatre
ans par chaque parti en guerre en
particulier dans la zone de sécurité
instauré par israël au liban sud depuis
1985 une bande de terre de 850
kilomètres carrés qui court de la
méditerranée à la lisière de la syrie
israël il ya des tâches et 1500 soldats
et entretient une force de deux mines
miliciens libani regroupés au sein de
l'armée du liban sud
sans arriver à maintenir durablement le
calme dans cette région
pour israël il s'agissait de répliquer
une activité du hezbollah chiite
libanais le problème israélien monsieur
moubarak étaient soumis à de fortes
pressions
après la mort de cinq militaires de
l'armée israélienne en moins de deux
semaines au nord d'israël ce matin des
localités de plus proche de la frontière
libanaise semblait déserte
jerusalem la correspondance de charles
enderlin l'alerté maintenue les
populations des régions proches de la
frontière libanaise sont priés de rester
dans les abris
tous les établissements d'enseignement
toutes les entreprises étaient fermés
aux jambes
l'armée craint une riposte dure
hesbollah des tirs de roquettes sur le
territoire israélien après les
bombardements de la nuit dernière au
liban est une nouvelle escalade toujours
possible au cours d'une visite dans les
abris de cris acciona et de ses environs
ehud barak le premier ministre a déclaré
que cette situation pourrait durer
plusieurs jours
il a annoncé qu'israël fera tout pour
défendre ses citoyens
il est poussé par une opinion publique
qui exige une opération d'envergure au
liban même laissé bien les isréliens
réagissait ainsi aux pertes croissantes
subis par leur armée au sud liban face à
la guérilla menée par le hezbollah
depuis le début de l'année six soldats
ont été tués et une dizaine sérieusement
blessé jusqu'à présent le res bola n'a
pas riposté en bombardant la galilée
si cela devait arriver et bien ehud
barak a promis de nouvelles représailles
encore plus importantes
une telle escalade pourraient être
catastrophiques pour le proche-orient
alors qu'israël n'entend plus observé
les accords de 1996 qui limite les
opérations militaires au sud liban alors
aussi que le processus de paix est dans
l'impasse
les etats-unis se sont déclarés très
inquiète escalade de la violence au
liban sud et la france a déploré les
bombardements menés par israël contre
des services publics indispensables au
liban à belgrade c'est le ministre de la
défense qui a été assassiné hier soir
alors qu'ils dînaient dans un restaurant
de banny cas c'est un quartier
résidentiel de la capitale serbe
pavel bulatovic originaire du monténégro
était un proche de ce que vous donne
milosevic son assassinat qui vient après
d'autres meurtres perpétrés contre des
landes du pouvoir semble avoir placé le
régime en état de choc l'assassin du
ministre a réussi à s'enfuir à l'état de
choc dû à cet assassinat d'un nom du
gouvernement s'ajoute aussi
découragement d'une population qui ne
voient guère les effets d'une
reconstruction
pourtant clamé par le régime de
milosevic à quelques kilomètres de
belgrade il ya le complexe pétrochimique
de pancevo souvent bombardé par
l'aviation de l'otan
il est réparée avec des moyens de
fortune et pancevo a causé d'autres
dégâts
les dégâts sur l'environnement sans
doute irrémédiable
nos envoyés spéciaux georges-besse
qu'emmanuel bec reviennent de pancevo
un cimetière industriel qui s'étend sur
des kilomètres plus de raffineries plus
de pétrochimie plus d'ammoniac en deux
mois l'otan réduit à néant le poumon
économique de la serbie mais à quel prix
ici il y avait 80 mille tonnes de
matières dangereuses qui se sont
répandus dans la terre plus de 20000
tonnes de matières cancérigènes et 8000
tonnes de mercure ce qui a contaminé le
sous sol et donc nous étions venus ici
en mai dernier pendant la guerre l'otan
avait détruit lusine d'ammoniaque qui
produisait entre autres des engrais pour
l'agriculture pour éviter le pire juste
avant les bombardements les 200 tonnes
d'ammoniac qui restait dans la cuve ont
été jetés dans le canal est donc dans le
danube
la pêche a été interdite pendant trois
mois dans toute la région
puis la mesure a été levée afin de
rassurer la population
les réparations ressemblent à des
rafistolages et si quelques usines ont
redémarré ce n'est que pour des raisons
politiques
sous la pression du régime afin de
montrer que la reconstruction avance
mais au mépris des règles de sécurité
presque collé à la zone industrielle les
premières maisons
chacun se souvient des bombardements de
jour comme de nuit
mais l'otan n'est pas seule mise en
cause dans la famille al hayat
on rappelle volontiers que nulle part
ailleurs on a construit une zone
industrielle si près de la ville à la
télévision on cherchera en vain des
informations sur l'état de la pollution
on a dit aux droits et aux roumains de
ne pas consommer leurs produits
protéiques alors que nous avons de chez
vous on nous a dit qu'il n'y avait pas
de pollution et que l'on pouvait manger
nos produits y compris après les
bombardements avaient dire avant les
bombardements au savait rien non plus de
la pollution
on nous cache et où pourtant les usines
étaient vétustes et on savait qu environ
4000 personnes étaient malades du cancer
les frappes ont sans doute aggraver les
choses monde s'en apercevra que dans 10
15 ou 20 ans
sur le marché les produits sont chers
comme partout en serbie du fait de
l'inflation mais chacun n'a qu'une idée
en tête
oui les gens ont peur ils demandent d'où
viennent les produits mais je les
rassure en leur expliquant que tout cela
a poussé après la guerre je ne réfléchis
plus on est devenus fatalistes
que l'on adhère ou non il faut bien
manger des centaines de milliers de
personnes ont donc été contaminés
provoquant beaucoup de maladies de peau
mais aussi des risques de malformations
pour les nouveaux nés
les gynécologues savent parfaitement
quels sont les effets du plomb et du
mercure pour les femmes son ca conseil
d'alors d'avoir recours ou non à
l'avortement
à votre avis est-ce qu'il est
souhaitable de faire des enfants à
pancevo dans les années qui viennent à
mon avis pas dans les deux trois ans à
venir
non belgrade n'est qu'à quelques
kilomètres de pancevo la capitale serbe
comme le danube d'ailleurs sont donc bel
et bien gravement pollué une réalité peu
évoquée en occident du fait de sa
responsabilité dans la guerre mais aussi
peut évoquer ici par le régime afin de
ne pas affoler la population en croatie
c'est le candidat centriste stipe et
médecine qui a remporté l'élection
présidentielle avec 56% des suffrages
type émises itx et pro-européen sa
victoire marque définitivement la fin du
régime mis en place par franz gertsch
man récemment décédé en grande bretagne
près de londres et stanstead l'avion
afghan où sont retenus 156 personnes en
otage par les guerres de l'air est
toujours bloqué au sol par les autorités
un nouveau passagers a été libéré en
début d'après midi si elle 9e des
négociations sont en cours
les proches du chef de guerre afghan
massoud réfute toutes les accusations de
complicité dans cette prise d'otage
accusations lancées par les talibans au
pouvoir à kaboul
et puis le départ du général pinochet
vers le chili est encore retarder la
haute cour de justice de londres
examinera le recours introduit par la
belgique ce recours était jugée conforme
par la cour d'appel de la haute cour
anglaise
le deuxième réseau de site le plus
visité sur internet yahoo a été victime
d'une attaque on a forcé le portail de
yahoo
et cette nouvelle version d'un cheval de
troie dans les circuits de la
communication informés
iq a bloqué le réseau pendant plus de
trois heures on parle d'un sabotage des
serveurs du groupe américain bombardé de
faux messages cela demande évidemment
quelques explications avec romain de
benet sur la page d'accueil de yahoo
aucune référence à l'attaqué
informatique dont la société
californienne a été victime pourtant
hier en pleine heure de pointe sur
l'internet aux états unis impossible
d'accéder aux sites de yahoo
l'un des principaux portails d'accès
pour la recherche d'informations
d'imagés de sons est resté complètement
fermé et inaccessible pour cause de
saturation
pendant trois heures des pirates ont
envoyé des millions de demandes sur le
site créant un véritable embouteillage
le procédé des questions envoyées en
boucle
grâce à un programme informatique sans
aucune réponse possible des pirates que
l'on appelle akers qu'il sera très
difficile d'identifier
des millions d'ha dresse différentes qui
nous arrive donc on croit que c'est des
millions d'utilisateurs mais c'est le
même le même à coeur ils simulent des
millions de requêtes différentes mais
c'est en général la même machine qui
fait tout ça donc tout le but essayer et
d'essayer d'aller plus vite que le
hacker pour pouvoir le coupé le plus tôt
possible
il y a deux mois ici au siège de yahoo
mais aussi chez tous ses concurrents
des agents du fbi y était venu pour
faire une mise en garde contre ce risque
d' attaques des outils permettant de
telles règles informatiques avaient été
découverts sur le net
mais pour l'heure les raisons de cette
offensive d'envergure reste mystérieuse
ça peut être une des jeunes hackers ou
pirates qui s'amusent parce qu'il ya une
sorte de défi et puis ça peut être une
motivation commerciale donc d'espionnage
commercial essayer de récupérer des
adresses essaie de récupérer les
fichiers clients de tous les gens qui
sont des utilisateurs diouf seul
commentaire chez yahoo
toutes nos excuses mais ça peut toujours
arriver autrement dit pas de parade
possible
seul réconfort pour le patron de yahoo
le cours de la bourse de son entreprise
a gagné 7 dollars aujourd'hui
il faudra sans doute beaucoup plus de 35
heures pour mettre au point les 35
heures dans la fonction publique les
négociations entamées hier autour du
ministre emile zuccarelli ont failli se
terminer par un fiasco à 4 heures du
matin les syndicats ont demandé aux
ministres de revoir sa copie avec une
revendication commune la création nette
d'emplois depuis 18 ans la discussion
repris pour tenter d'élaborer un accord
cadre sur la réduction du temps de
travail dans la fonction publique
outre le fait que cela concerne plus de
5 millions de personnes n'est pas facile
de s'y retrouver dans les différentes
revendications
compte tenu de la multiplicité des
secteurs concernés avec jean bernard
schmidt et christian galley nous avons
pris trois exemples dans cette heure
santé le secteur culturel et
l'enseignement
ils savent qui sont autour de cette
table pour un bon moment car autant de
fonctionnaires autant de cas particulier
à traiter
parmi eux trois exemples trois
situations différentes
l'éducation nationale premier employeur
de france
sept cent mille enseignants qui
travaillent en moyenne 38 heures par
semaine entre les cours et les
préparations problème difficile de
comparer l'emploi du temps d'un
instituteur et d'un prof de fac pour les
syndicats pas de mystère passés aux 35
heures c'est créer de nouveaux postes
autre revendication l'intégration de
cent mille enseignants en situation
précaire il faut transformer ces emplois
précaires en emplois stables de
personnel formé
recrutés selon des normes qui leur
permettent d'exercer d'avoir un
déroulement de carrière
deuxième exemple les personnels
infirmiers ils sont 180 milles pour des
durées de travail très variable selon
les syndicats là encore il faut des
embauches il en réclame douze mille et
une réorganisation totale du métier
des négociations sont d'ailleurs en
cours avec martine aubry pour remettre à
plat toute la profession dernier cas
problématiques
les personnels de la culture vingt mille
agents et des situations très diverses
de 29 à 39 heures de travail par semaine
les syndicats demandent si la
titularisation des personnes en contrat
précaire 12% du total et de nouvelles
embauches car les métiers ont changé
tous ces nouveaux métiers nécessitent
évidemment d'embauché mis nos sites nous
disons plusieurs centaines de personnes
pour effectivement remplir ses missions
ses nouvelles missions du service public
culturel pour les négociateurs le
chantier est immense
la seule régularisation des précaires
concernerait un million de personnes
dans la fonction publique
alors pascal golomer où en est on des
discussions depuis 18h cotation reprend
claude ministère de la fonction publique
à partir d'un nouveau projet d'accord
qu'emile zuccarelli a présenté aux sept
fédérations syndicales peu après 18
heures un projet d'accord qui certes
n'évoquent toujours pas de création
d'emplois liés directement au passage
aux 35 heures mais qui prévoit de
compenser globalement les départs en
retraite jusqu'en 2003 et de remplacer
en priorité les postes des agents en
situation précaire par des postes de
titulaires alors le texte en l'état nous
convient toujours pas aux syndicats mais
le ton des commentaires a changé et on
est loin en tous cas du front du refus
ficher tout au long de la nuit dernière
parce qu'il y aura peut-être un deuxième
round 6 jeudi à chaque ministère chaque
miss j'avais envie de gérer son propre
secteur
c'est vrai qu au temps et emile
zuccarelli estime indispensable la
signature d'un tel accord au nom de
l'unicité du service public
autant certains de ses collègues
ministres ont sans doute intérêt ou
préférerait sans doute négocier
eux-mêmes secteur par secteur pour
annoncer pourquoi pas des créations
d'emplois et en tirer profit
personnellement ou tout simplement pour
ne pas avoir à se référer à tel ou tel
paragraphe contraignant de
l'accord-cadre voilà d'ailleurs pourquoi
ce soir les syndicats semblent bien
résolue aboutir à une signature
merci pascal j'ajoute que la fédération
cgt de la poste appellent à une semaine
d'actions du 21 au 26 février pour être
là mais des créations d'emplois à rennes
une grève de postiers est en cours
depuis neuf jours toujours sur la mise
en place des 35 heures ça coince dur
chez les routiers les négociations entre
patronat et syndicats ont entamé cet
après-midi ont été suspendus à devait
porter sur les salaires mais les
représentants patronaux n'avait
apparemment pas de mandat de négociation
précis c'est du moins ce que pense et
syndicats depuis sa tension est
perceptible au sein des syndicats le
leader de force ouvrière projet
politique que l'on voit ici sortir
difficilement de la mêlée a été conspué
par des manifestants ciel d'été il avait
déclaré lors de la levée des barrages
que la cgt la cgt avait trahi
et puis ce soir marc blondel de force
ouvrière accuse de la cfdt transport de
méthodes fascisantes par l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre en
répondant à une question d'un député rpr
a affirmé qu'il ne saurait être question
d'engager des discussions secrètes avec
les mouvements nationalistes clandestins
corses pas plus qu'il ne veut entendre
parler d' amnistie question de
l'amnistié que vous avez évoqué l n'être
en rien une question que je me pose je
m'en tiens au dialogue politique que
j'ai noué
c'est ce dialogue que je veux avancer
je ne sais pas si je pourrai le faire
déboucher cela dépendra des élus de la
corse
cela dépendra peut-être décor ce même si
nous décidons ensemble et avec une autre
autorité de l'état de leur demander leur
avis quelle qu'en soit la forme
cela dépendra sans doute de vous aussi
et peut-être d'une autre assemblée si
des propositions nous étaient faites
et il faudra bien donc trouver un accord
une forme de consensus pour essayer de
trouver des solutions
mais la question de la mystique que vous
évoquez n'étant rien pour moi une
question que je me pose bien sur france
inter il ya quelques minutes vient de
lui répondre un élu de l'assemblée
territoriale le nationaliste jean-guy
talamoni l'aministie c'est une question
qui se pose une question qui se posera
inévitablement c'est d'ailleurs une
revendication nationaliste une dire jean
guy talamoni sur france inter
l'assemblée nationale qui examinait en
début de soirée pour une troisième
lecture les deux projets de loi visant à
limiter strictement le cumul des mandats
la réforme voulue par le gouvernement
semble bloqué le sénat ne veut pas dans
sa majorité que les députés les
sénateurs soit empêchée d'exercer une
fonction exécutive locale
c'est donc un recul sur la gauche qui
s'annonce sa part est plutôt probable
d'ailleurs jacques lang appelle lui-même
a renoncé au projet de réforme
et pourtant cette limitation du nombre
des mandats a fait l'objet de man
déclarations de mme anne promesses par
le passé à droite comme à gauche ce que
nous rappelle maintenant philippe
boisserie et michel levasseur limiter
strictement le cumul des mandats est
ainsi devenue une priorité
la législation sur le cumul des mandats
et sur les incompatibilités sera
renforcée notamment en ce qui concerne
les fonctions exécutives locales
dès son discours de politique générale
lionel jospin avait fixé le cap
le cumul des mandats ne devait plus être
une des traditions de la culture
politique française
pour bien montrer l'exemple les
ministres de son gouvernement comme par
exemple catherine trautmann à strasbourg
devait abandonner leur casquette de
maire de bonnes intentions qui trouvait
un relais jusqu'à l'elysée fait
favorable à la limitation du cumul des
mandats et même à l'arrêt ce truc à la
restriction à seul mandat le mais voilà
comme la loi qui interdit le cumul entre
un mandat national et une fonction
exécutive locale est une loi organique
elle doit être votée à l'identique à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
de fait lève la main et comme lorsque
les députés a adopté un texte les
sénateurs ont voté un autre le projet de
loi s'est mise à faire la navette entre
les deux assemblées sans que le fossé
arrive à se combler la france
deviendrait ingérable
elles seraient bien sûr administrés par
des gens qui seraient élus et désignés
par les formations politiques sans avoir
d'assises locale ça ne me paraît pas
devant cette opposition systématique de
sénateurs majoritaires à droite et
dépendant des élus locaux pour leur
élection
jack lang a aujourd'hui lancé un pavé
dans la mare vieux voudrait en effet
s'accorder un peu de temps
pour réaliser la grande réforme que nous
avions souhaité je le répète la
suppression de tout cumul des fonctions
et des mandats
à droite le temps n'est toujours pas aux
concessions mais aux conditions si c'est
pour remplacer le cumul des mandats par
le cumul d'un mandat avec une profession
alors qu'il ya de vrai un comptable
incompatibilité là aussi c'est un coup
d'épée dans l'eau
en troisième lecture le texte risque
donc de se limiter aux élus locaux et
européens et d'épargner les élus
nationaux dans la bataille politique les
bonnes intentions se réduisent parfois
comme peau de chagrin
et cet ancrage dans la vie locale qui
est largement souhaitée par les
parlementaires y compris à gauche irait
donc contre une limitation du cumul des
mandats électifs pour le comprendre nous
nous sommes intéressés avec alban
nicosie et carole comme on a deux hommes
tous les deux présidents de région tous
les deux députés tous les deux engagés
dans la gestion de leur commune il
s'agit de michel vauzelle à arles et de
françois fillon à sablé dans la sarthe
l'un et l'autre s'organise très bien et
la situation actuelle semble leur
convenir
michel vauzelle socialiste votre altec
sur le non-cumul françois fillon rpr ce
sera plus réticents comme la grande
majorité des parlementaires françois
fillon est ce qu'on appelle un cumulard
dont jours par semaine il retrouve
l'assemblée nationale pour y exercer son
mandat s'il déplore le manque de
pouvoirs du parlement dans nos
institutions la fonction de député
reste pour lui un passage obligé c'est
le mandat de député qui offre une
tribune nationale vont tribune qui
permet d'exprimer ses opinions
ces projets en les appuyant sur la
connaissance de la réalité locale
l'analyse est partagée par le socialiste
michel vauzelle pour lui les problèmes
d'emploi du temps son secondaire et
l'expérience acquise au fil des mandats
profite aux électeurs on pourrait
imaginer un système où on élire les
députés au scrutin de listes nationales
comme les députés européens
là il y aurait plus du tout de nécessité
pour le député d'aller prendre un petit
café bistro du coin avec les électeurs
ça serait à mon avis une conception
terrifiante pour la démocratie française
le terrain c'est nantes capitale de la
région des pays de la loire depuis deux
ans françois fillon il préside le
conseil régional également maire d'une
petite commune
il juge la législation en vigueur sur le
cumul des mandats plutôt satisfaisante
et préférerait le statu quo ou alors une
réforme complète des institutions si on
va vers un régime présidentiel avec un
parlement plus puissant si on va vers
des collectivités locales ayant
réellement des nouvelles compétences
c'est-à-dire un système plus
décentralisé
alors évidemment le cumul des mandats
apparaîtra comme impossible de fait et
il faudra y mettre un terme
en attendant michel vauzelle conservera
donc la présidence de la région provence
alpes côte d'azur ses fonctions de
député il son poste d'adjoint à la
mairie d'arles il votera pour le texte
sur le cumul des mandats par discipline
de parti mais sans pour autant paraître
se déjuger que je crois que la
démocratie est une chose vivante comme
la république et que pour rester vivante
elle doit rester continuellement en
adéquation avec l'évolution des moeurs
et des mentalités sur la modernisation
de la vie politique tout le monde est
donc d'accord mais à la condition que
son application se fasse très
progressivement
plusieurs sections de revendications du
actuellement dans l'éducation nationale
en france dans l'hérault à toulouse en
quartier du mirail en moselle dans le
district de dai anges à lille et dans le
gard dans ce dernier département 1800
enseignant sur trois milles sur est en
grève pour obtenir plus de moyens il
souhaite globalement la création de 500
emplois enseignants et personnels
d'éducation compris plusieurs écoles
sont occupés voyez le reportage dans le
gard de karine comazzi et denis pardonne
au lendemain de leur évacuation forcée
de l'inspection académique les
enseignants de maternelle et du primaire
resserrent les rangs derrière leur
intersyndicale de nouvelles écoles du
gard ont rejoint ce matin un mouvement
qui entre dans sa deuxième semaine
aujourd'hui ça déborde ça déborde
notamment par rapport au remplacement
par rapport à l'accueil des enfants en
maternelle par rapport au réseau
dead et de soutien aux élèves en
difficulté les grévistes réclament 500
postes d'enseignants dans un département
qui compte déjà trois mille instituteurs
une revendication jugée utopique par
l'inspecteur d'académie le réalité du
terrain
c'est que depuis 95 le gars a perdu 1200
élèves et a gagné 28 postes le taux
d'encadrement c'est donc très
sensiblement améliorées une amélioration
qui aura échappé à françoise et
christophe tous deux enseignent en zone
d'éducation prioritaire
là où le nombre maximum d'élèves est
théoriquement de 24 par classe
j'ai trente et un élèves en cm2 en zep
dans les quartiers donc c'est
défavorisés et dès qu'un collègue est
absent photo avec 32 33 élèves
ce qu'il faut se partager les élèves
comme les parents travaillent ils sont
clairs
trente et un élèves en classe ça pose
des problèmes de places j'ouvre plus mes
armoires 31 élèves ça m'est impossible
d'aller dans la sphère politique qui ne
peut en accueillir que 24 se sont pas
des conditions de travail acceptables et
c'est pour ça à les parents l'ont
compris c'est pour ça qu'ils nous qui
nous aident et la seule réponse qu'on a
trouvé un autre besoin jusqu'à
maintenant ce sont des emplois jeunes
mais c'est pas ça qui demande au ce sont
des enseignants de les trois quarts des
écoles les enseignants sont en grève
jusqu'à jeudi avec 500 postes
ils attendent beaucoup de la carte
scolaire la question d'oublier la marée
noire elle vient de se rappeler au
mauvais souvenir des habitants des
communes de la turballe et du croisic en
loire atlantique des plaques
d'hydrocarbures à porter par les
courants les derniers vents violents
sont revenus et sont sans doute issu du
pétrolier erika elles sont revenues sur
les côtes depuis la turballe jusqu'au
moutiers-en-retz c'est au sud du
département de loire atlantique
en une dizaine de jours trois cas de
méningite dans le jura ont été déclarées
l'état de santé de l'adolescent
scolarisé au collège gabriel rosset 7 à
lyon s'est légèrement améliorée
aujourd'hui
d'autre part on a appris le décès
aujourd'hui d'une adolescente de 15 ans
près de fribourg en suisse jeune fille
était atteinte d'une méningite
cette maladie causerait plusieurs
dizaines de morts en france chaque année
à l'affect souvent les collectivités
abritant des enfants et des jeunes
adultes cette maladie est une atteinte
infectieuses des ménages qui enveloppe
le cerveau et la moelle épinière
benoît thevenet avec frédéric juin
pierre moscovici nous livre quelques
explications sur la méningite et les
moyens de la combattre à l'auscultation
quelques gestes suffisent aux médecins
pour suspecter la présence d'une
méningite cérébrospinale l'infection se
caractérise notamment par de la fièvre
une raideur douloureuse de la nuque des
vomissements
la photophobie c'est à dire des
éblouissements et éventuellement des
taches rouges sur le corps
la bactérie responsable la voici
grossissant mille fois le méningocoque
une personne sur dix ans n'a au fond de
la gorge où elle est inoffensive mais
sans que l'on puisse expliquer pourquoi
la bactérie passe parfois dans le sang
puis dans les méninges c'est à dire les
tissus qui entoure la moelle épinière et
le cerveau faute de traitement
l'infection peut provoquer coma et
septicémie il existe trois souches
différentes de méningocoque l'aa très
rare l'abbé la plus répandue est là
c'est pour les 30% restants pour la
méningite b de méningocoque b qui est la
plus courante il faut obligatoirement
donner immédiatement d antibiotique
préventif pour la méningite à
méningocoque c 30 % des cas on a un
vaccin mais en attendant que le vaccin
fasse son effet il faut aussi donner
dans l'immédiat des antibiotiques pour
éliminer méningocoque de la gorge
tourner qu'il faut toujours donner un
traitement antibiotique préventif aux
sujets contacts car malgré son extrême
fragilité
il arrive que le méningocoque passe
d'une personne à l'autre par
l'intermédiaire de la salie il faut donc
traiter l'entourage de la personne
malade
la famille ainsi que la classe de
l'enfant ou la crèche pour les tout
petits on appris également l'habitude de
donner des antibiotiques à l'ensemble
d'une école d'une caserne ou d'une
colonie mais le but est seulement de
rassurer
en france on dénombre chaque année 400
cas de méningite cérébrospinale dans 10%
des cas comme à bourgoin jallieu la
semaine dernière l'infection provoque le
décès du malade
une nouvelle alerte à la listeria
concernant des fromages des lots de
tranche est de raclette ont été retirés
du marché voici les coordonnées de ces
lots certains ont des dates
d'utilisation maximal 15 mars d'autres
15 ou 16 février je vous laisse noter
ses applications et puis par ailleurs l'
usine de brioude qui produit ces
tranches est de raclette c'est en haute
loire a arrêté sa production pour huit
jours cela ressemble enfin à une
information heureuse une histoire
exemplaire celle de mineurs du pays de
galles qui n'ont pas accepté en 94
d'être dépossédés de leur outil de
travail contre toutes les logiques
économiques
ils ont racheté leur mine six ans plus
tard il continue de bâtir ce qu
autrefois on appelait les lendemains qui
chantent cette histoire est devenu aussi
un film documentaire de jean-michel
carré intitulé charbon ardent qui sera
dès demain sur les écrans de cinéma en
france
nathalie moisins patrick descheemaecker
et olivier journée à raconte cette
aventure des mineurs gallois elle devait
être rayé du paysage la mine n'a plus
d'avenir disaient les politiques mais
parce qu'ils croyaient en leur charbon
les gueules noires ont inversé le cours
de l'histoire
194 8 mois après la fermeture avec leurs
indemnités de licenciement
il rachète la mine cinq ans plus tard
l'utopie vit toujours les charbonnages
britannique disait que la mine ne valait
rien qu'on ne pouvait pas gagner de
l'argent maintenant on leur a prouvé à
eux et aux autres qu'on pouvait en
gagner que ça pouvait marcher
fierté de leur réussit ici les 400
mineurs sont tous co actionnaires et
quand on leur demande pourquoi ils ont
accepté le pari ils répondent qu'ils
n'avaient pas le choix
la mort de leur mine c'était la mort de
leurs valets on n'avait nulle part où
aller on était le dos au mur il n'y
avait pas d'emploi c'était la seule
chose à faire c est quand même là ouvert
qu'est ce que voulaient les tensions
c'était merveilleux le plus beau cadeau
qu'on n'ait jamais eu un sentiment
magnifique double un enthousiasme qui
explique le faible taux d'absentéisme
qui a fait de cette mine la plus sûre du
pays
dans cette salle à chaque retour d'une
équipe ses délégués font 50 rendu
destinées à améliorer la sécurité
mais l'apprentissage de la cogestion ne
s'est pas fait sans mal une règle c'est
imposer la discipline
il faut se dire qu'on est un employé
pendant 361 jours et patrons quatre
jours pour les réunions annuelles si on
se disait qu'on est propriétaire de la
mine
chaque jour de l'année chacun dirait
j'ai plus besoin de faire ci ou ça
je suis le patron dans cette mine où
l'ouvrier fume le cigare les salles et
retourne au taux de 15 mille francs par
mois la clé du succès la diversification
des marchés d'exportation en france et
belgique
la production est passé de 400 à 600
mille tonnes en quatre ans pour l'ancien
leader syndical devenu patron la fin
programmée du charbonnage était plus
politique qu'économique
la volonté selon lui peut tout le
charbon n'est pas plus doux parce qu'on
est propriétaire de la mine la cie n'est
pas plus léger en est propriétaire mais
ce que ça change c'est que ça nous
appartient et on a confiance en chacun y
sommes
dans la vallée qui a vu naître le
drapeau rouge pour son cinquième
anniversaire depuis la réouverture
la mine est à la fête mais pour combien
de temps encore le filon de charbon sera
épuisé dans dix ans de quoi permettre
seulement aux mineurs actuelle d'elle
jusqu'à la retraite
et puis je rappelle le documentaire le
film qui sort sur les écrans de jean
michel carré charbons ardents sur cette
histoire du sport aux championnats
d'europe de patinage artistique qui se
déroule à vienne en autriche dans les
épreuves de danse après les premières
compétitions de figures imposées ce sont
les français ici marie marina anissina
et gwendal peizerat qui sont en fait
pour les couples en revanche l'autre
couple français
sarah abitbol et stéphane bernadis ne
sont que 5e du programme court en
patinage artistique
et revoilà secure le groupe anglais qui
se fit connaître en 1979 était en
concert hier soir à paris à la défense
pour présenter son onzième album de
chios c'est presque un symbole des
années 80 aujourd'hui cultive un peu la
mélancolie d'un leur dernier album blood
of flowers fleurs de sang pierre
emmanuel luneau et frédéric de la rue en
suivi le concert et nous rappelle
quelques petites choses qu'il faut
évidemment savoir sur ce court si l'on
devait ne retenir qu'une silhouette du
rock des années 80 ce serait peut-être
celle du chanteur des tubes
depuis sa naissance en 1979 le groupe a
imposé sa marque et en concert à paris
pour présenter cet album
la recette fonctionne toujours
je n'ai pu l'être
même un joueur suisse quand il ya un peu
près
en passant par cette question de
nostalgie l'alchimie était là vraiment
la secoue
c'est un groupe anglais du nord de
l'angleterre cette alchimie si
particulières le groupe
la forge au beau milieu d'une décennie
où l'individualisme et l'argent sont
rois payet qui ouvre répond par le noir
au machisme par une attitude androgyne
et à la musique de discothèque le groupe
oppose ses influences classiques et ses
guitares torturés
pour des millions de fans ce groupe
devient alors un mythe et son chanteur
une idole
depuis sa création 21 millions d'albums
ont été vendus de par le monde
à 40 ans aujourd'hui robert smith a
choisi de rester fidèle aux kurdes et
des bus au risque de paraître démodé
je crois que nous sommes plus qu'un
simple groupe de types qui font de la
musique
il reste très peu de groupes comme nous
dans lesquels le public investi ses
émotions et ses come back
comme un grand frère un peu triste mais
très doué on sait maintenant que robert
smith et sa musique resteront longtemps
encore à nos côtés et puis nous faut
rendre hommage quelqu'un qui faisait
partie de la télévision on a appris
aujourd'hui le décès du comédien sylvain
joubert à l'âge de 55 ans une grande
partie de son activité artistique se fie
à la télévision où il a interprété
quelques 80 rôle une série ardéchois
coeurs fidèles
vous voyez un extrait l'a rendu célèbre
et populaire sylvain joubert avait aussi
écrit un très beau roman de crimes de
guerre qui fut adapté à la télévision
nous arrivons à la fin de sédition je
vous rappelle l'actualité concernant
israël et le liban le bombardement la
nuit dernière dans plusieurs lieux du
liban des sites industriels par
l'aviation israélienne
après la mort de six soldats isréliens
l'une en sus des moubarak avait décidé
de riposter
les raids ont blessé 18 civils il y à de
gros dégâts matériels qu israël qui
récuse maintenant l'accord de 96 sur la
propulsion des populations civiles du
livre ancien
dans quelques secondes sophie davant
pour la météo et puis après manon des
sources va nous en 55 alors heureux le
magazine présenté par frédéric lopez à
zéro heure quarante vols et laurence
ostolaza pour dernier journal de la
rédaction
demain c'est à 50 de françoise laborde
recevra pierre parce que ici le ministre
des affaires européennes
et puis après heure vous trouvez que
carole gaessler et rachid arhab à demain
20h bonsoir merci